The Resistance got a badass, purple-haired
new leader in Star Wars: The Last Jedi, with
Laura Dern joining the series as Vice Admiral
Amilyn Holdo.
We're not going to spoil her role for you
here, but anyone who's seen the film knows
how important she is—and how stellar Dern
was in the part.
For those wondering where you've seen her
before, here's why Vice Admiral Holdo looks
so familiar.
Rambling Rose
Dern is the daughter of screen veterans Diane
Ladd and Bruce Dern, so she had no trouble
breaking into the business in the '80s with
movies like Mask, Smooth Talk, Wild at Heart,
and Blue Velvet.
Dern really entered the spotlight, though,
with her starring role as the title character
in 1991's Rambling Rose.
Starring opposite her mother, she earned widespread
critical admiration—and her first Oscar
nomination.
Jurassic Park
A year after she broke into the big time,
Dern joined the blockbuster fold by starring
in the big screen adaptation of Michael Crichton's
Jurassic Park as Dr. Ellie Sattler.
Jurassic Park ended up being a huge box office
success and was also a hit with critics.
The film spawned two sequels, and Dern had
a brief cameo in Jurassic Park III.
Now that the series has been rebooted with
Jurassic World, Dern has hinted that she might
be reprising her old role again sooner than
later.
"She's a tough feminist!"
"We need her back."
Citizen Ruth
Dern also starred in Alexander Payne's first
notable feature, Citizen Ruth, as the title
character, a poor pregnant woman who becomes
a central figure in the national debate about
abortion.
Dern said she suspected that Payne would be
the next big thing when she signed on to Citizen
Ruth, and her respect for the director may
be part of why she decided to work with him
again in his 2017 feature Downsizing, which
arrived in theaters just a week after The
Last Jedi.
October Sky
Dern's last role of the 20th century came
in 1999's October Sky, a bio-pic in which
she played the inspirational science teacher
to a group of children who took to rocketry
as a way of escaping their mining town.
Her character was an advocate and a source
of strength for the boys throughout, and served
as one of the only likable adults in the movie.
Recount
In 2008, Dern helped HBO rehash a political
scandal in the TV movie Recount, which followed
the controversy surrounding the 2000 presidential
election.
In the film, Dern plays Katherine Harris,
then Secretary of State of Florida, where
a recount controversy erupted between candidates
George W. Bush and Al Gore.
Dern earned her second Golden Globe win for
the part and was also nominated for an Emmy,
a SAG Award, and more.
Dern said she learned a great deal from the
experience of playing such a controversial
real-life figure, telling the Washington Post:
"Recount taught me a lot because my dad told
me you can never hate the characters you play
and you have to love your characters…"
"I had to just figure out how to give some
humanity and depth of passion to a person
that had become a huge stereotype in this
country."
Enlightened
Her next small screen role of note was in
HBO's critically acclaimed dramedy series
Enlightened.
"I will kill you motherf---er."
On the show, Dern played Amy Jellicoe, a woman
who, after a nervous breakdown, comes back
to work with a new outlook on life.
Dern collected another Golden Globe win and
an Emmy nomination for the show and served
as both co-creator and star.
However, like many critically acclaimed dramas
in the era of peak TV, Enlightened never found
a big audience, and the show was canceled
after just two seasons.
The Fault in Our Stars
In 2014, Dern went back to the mainstream
for the teen-oriented romantic comedy The
Fault in Our Stars.
The movie, based on the John Green novel of
the same name, featured Dern as the mother
of Shailene Woodley's Hazel Grace Lancaster,
a teenager who falls in love while she deals
with terminal thyroid cancer.
The film was a critical success and arrived
as a box office smash.
Wild
It took Dern over 20 years to earn another
Academy Award nomination after Rambling Rose,
but her nod for 2014's Wild was certainly
well-deserved.
Dern starred in the film as the mother of
Reese Witherspoon's Cheryl Strayed, who flashes
back to her childhood as she hikes up the
Pacific Crest Trail trying to discover her
true self.
Not only was her performance celebrated, but
it wouldn't be the last buzzy collaboration
she'd have with Witherspoon.
Big Little Lies
HBO's latest awards season darling, Big Little
Lies, has earned nods for all of its main
stars at the Emmys, the Golden Globes, and
more.
In the series, Dern plays Renata Klein, the
uptight nemesis of Reese Witherspoon's Madeline
McKenzie.
And Dern walked away with a Golden Globe nomination
and an Emmy win, beating out her co-star Shailene
Woodley for the latter award.
Although Big Little Lies was initially billed
as a limited series, it's been renewed for
a second season following overwhelming fan
demand.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!